[Música]
spectrum
escriba cuando estaría en si les
preguntara si no entienden a la versión
a unos colegios que pensarían si
responde la pregunta con todos ustedes y
les dijera que inconscientemente todos
no tenemos acá para descargar incluso
contractivo después de todo como
podremos tenerlo cuando es una de las
principales fuentes del pensamiento
innovador de pimientos cuando sabemos
que hacen los temas más resilientes
la diversidad es fundamental para
nuestra supervivencia y sin embargo de
términos
la biología evolutiva y la neurociencia
nos explican por qué
verán este miedo se encuentra en el
sistema olímpico el pueblo 21 hacen
vídeos de años entre otras cosas para
indicarnos que haya dos formas de vida
distintas a nosotros eran un potencial
peligro y así generar miedo la verdad es
que es muy afortunado que las cosas se
han dado así porque este miedo jugó un
rol de gran importancia en nuestra
evolución
sé que parece fuera de nuestra época
anacrónico después de todo ya veremos en
las cuevas no dependemos de la casa
mucho menos somos presas entonces por
qué seguir también muy fácil nuestro
cerebro no evoluciona ahora mismo del
estado en que lo ha hecho una sociedad
el sistema límbico y sus lecturas aún
están tratando de ponerse al corriente
con los drásticos cambios que nuestra
forma de vida ha tenido en los últimos
cientos de años la verdad es que después
de ver cómo es que he estado lidia con
la diversidad y de entrada me de que de
hecho le tenemos miedo a la misma las
cosas se hicieron mucho más sentido todo
hizo clic les explicó el sistema
jurídico tiene dos formas tradicionales
de tratar con la diversidad la primera
es la hace relación ciertamente esta es
la medida más radical tal como lo hizo
en la parte de insúa las razas estaban
geográficamente separados no serían
educarían e incluso morirían separados
sé que esto fue una estrategia de la
minoría blanca el 21 por ciento para
conservar el poder político en el país
pero este alrededor también es evidencia
desde el miedo inconsciente que
dependamos en la universidad finalmente
si yo reservo un territorio únicamente
para mí y aquellos que comparten mi raza
estoy negando la diversidad hasta ciento
cuando estoy viviendo de ella y
recordamos sólo vimos de aquellas cosas
a las que tengamos miedo
la segunda forma en que es tratado con
la diversidad ha sido a través de los
interactivos de igualdad formal
a qué me refiero con eso
bueno las cuestiones que vienen en la
declaración de los derechos del hombre
del ciudadano de 1789 en las que decía
los hombres no son libres e iguales
en serio igual es que consta que no
estoy en desacuerdo con el principio de
igualdad ante la ley que hace que los
legisladores no puedan aprobar leyes
discriminatorias no obstante si me pongo
a crear estados y piensen que todos
somos iguales porque sólo podemos
hacerlo entonces en tanto se nos consiga
en abstracto
independientemente de nuestro género
religión nacionalidad etnia y
preferencia sexual una vez más nuestro
miedo inconsciente a la diversidad nos
traiciona nos hace crear estados ciegos
a la diversidad y que por tanto no
pueden ser más que indiferentes a él
y terminamos legislando para estos
sujetos libres iguales en lugar de
hacerlo para los grupos indígenas para
los migrantes para las mujeres para
estas minorías que verdaderamente lo
necesitan
qué hace ante esta situación
primero reconozcamos que por una
cuestión fisiológica aún le tememos a la
diversidad para así poder evaluar en qué
medida nuestras acciones play son
estados o sus políticas públicas están
conducidas por este tema
segundo sé que vamos a tardar pero
deberíamos de hablar de diversidad la
diversidad es una condición innata de la
naturaleza ya está ahí
en cambio discutamos cómo hacer que
diferente no sea aguada desfavorecido no
sea igual a marginal conversamos acerca
de cómo vamos a proteger a estas
personas que son distintas
tercero dejemos de pensar que el
interactivo de igualdad formal es
suficiente porque no lo es que ha
permitido muchos edificios george orwell
de hecho en su libro rebelión de la
granja lo ilustra muy bien el séptimo
mandamiento decía todos los animales son
iguales la verdad es que sean los
caballos gallinas perros ovejas
no lo verán el resto de los mandamientos
no pudo porque tiene a nosotros animales
de los arrebatos de los hermosos porque
eran incapaces de identificar sus
diferencias por lo tanto nunca pudieron
verlos como un grupo vulnerable y mucho
menos proteger más como tal este
imperativo de igualdad formal terminó
fundando un sistema entre facto todos
los animales eran iguales pero unos más
iguales que otros
entonces conseguiría una propuesta
basada en 23 puntos que el estado del
propone
en el contexto de méxico sería algo así
bajo la premisa de que el 10% de nuestra
población son grupos indígenas y que los
mismos están marginados y por ende en
condiciones de su representación
política podremos hacer algo así de que
las elecciones están de moda porque no
proponer una reforma al sistema
electoral mexicano para que cualquier
candidato pueda llegar a la presidencia
tenga que tener un tercio de los votos
en los cinco estados con mayor población
de nvidia
esta es una primera medida para subsanar
esa sub representación política a la que
se enfrentan el díaz por ciento de
nuestra población
todos los indígenas
seguramente hay otros propuestos quizá
ustedes que ahora se escuchan estén
pensando en la propia
entonces les digo recuerdo en la
universidad porque en su miedo
inconsciente a la misma la niega está
negándose en sí mismo gracias